eine landschaft um wirklich und karl
trotzdem haben sich hier menschen
niedergelassen
diese farben sind geradezu psychedelisch
die warnsignale
natürlich sehen die nicht auf ein
idyllisches tropen ein land das die
naturgewalten zu spüren bekam
[Musik]
die leute glaubten kaum dass im radio
hört das war seit 300 jahren nicht mehr
kassiert mein name ist ernst die ganze
insel wurde kalt erwischt
eine geister flotte im wüstensand
gestrandet
schiffe in der wüste wo ein schiff ist
da es normalerweise auch das aber er ist
weit und breit kein
und eine sammlung einst prachtvolle
gebäude jetzt überwältigt von der natur
das eingangstor eingestürzt eine
laufbahn aufgeworfen und voller risse
und plötzlich wird klar das war eine
schule
zerfallende bauten ruinen aus
vergangener zeit
einst mühsam erschaffen heute nur noch
schatten ihrer selbst
zeit ihre geheimnisse zu lüften
[Musik]
im norden äthiopiens eine landschaft wie
von einem anderen stern sie steckt
voller gefahren
das ist einer der seltsamsten orte der
erde
ist eine landschaft ohne jede spur von
seines tier oder pflanze
rätselhafte farben 14 schülern dem
wasser geysire heiße quellen es gibt
nichts vergleichbares
eine fremdartige landschaft die felsen
leuchtend gelb grün und rot
im grunde ist es ein brett
meilenweit gibt es keinen schatten keine
vegetation und die sonne brennt
erbarmungslos
wahrlich kein ort für menschen und doch
waren sie da
dieser unwirtlichen landschaft erheben
sich die ruinen einer siedlung häuser
kaputte last waren
reste einer infrastruktur
und alles ist irgendwie verkrustet und
wie mit dem boden verwachsen
heute ist das dorf trostlos und
verlassen aber es gab eine zeit in der
menschen entschlossen waren hier zu
leben
das land der toten
warum
[Musik]
orthopäde ist einheimischer führer und
experte für diesen extremen ort
[Musik]
das ist eine wirklich unbarmherzige
gegend deshalb liegen hier so viele
skelette herum
der tiefste gelegenen und heißesten orte
der welt 120 meter unter dem
meeresspiegel
das quecksilber steigt hier auf bis zu
50 grad celsius
aber es sind nicht nur die temperaturen
die diesen ort so lebensfeindlich machen
[Musik]
unter den füßen hat man die salzige
kruste knacken
wenn man zu nah an einen dieser tümpel
kommt kann das ziemlich gefährlich
werden
deren ph wert kann bei 1 oder weniger
liegen
das ist dann wie schwefelsäure
wenn man durch die salzkruste bricht
kann man sich verletzen das ist nicht
ohne
an dieser stelle driften zwei
tektonische platten aus
die erde wird buchstäblich aufgerissen
und doch stehen hier umgeben von
giftigen quellen die überreste einer
siedlung das ist die stadt dabei
[Musik]
jetzt ist nicht mehr viel hier aber es
gibt nach hinweise auf die vergangenheit
gebäude reste von maschinen gehandelt
das beweist dass tatsächlich menschen
hier waren was für ein ort zum leben
des rätsels lösung liegt unter der
oberfläche
[Musik]
bis dieser verrückte boden hat mehr mit
chemie als mit biologie zu tun und ist
der grund warum menschen hierher kamen
hier gibt es einen vulkan der durch all
diese geschichten aus bricht
er interagiert mit dem gestein und das
salz löst sich auf dann entstehen ganz
besondere hydrothermale säuren
der boden ist voll mit chemikalien und
salzen das verursacht all die seltsamen
farben tümpel und geysiren es ist eine
art chemisches wunderland
ein element das hier vorkommt ist auf
der ganzen welt gefragt
eine besondere ablagerung ist das
kalisalz oder pottasche ein mischmasch
aus verschiedenen chemikalien der viel
kalium enthält
eine so hohe konzentration von kaviza so
nah an der erdoberfläche
ohne großen aufwand dass er sich einfach
vom boden kratzen
kali salz wird als dünger und für die
chemische industrie verwendet und hier
liegt es direkt an der oberfläche
1912 erwerben zwei italienische
abenteurer die erste konzession schon
bald beginnt der abbau der wertvollen
ressource in industriellem maßstab
es gab eine große nachfrage nach
kalisalz die landwirtschaft nahm
weltweit zu immer mehr dünger wurde
gebraucht deshalb kamen mehr und mehr
arbeiter hierher
sie bauen ihre häuser einfach an ort und
stelle
[Musik]
arbeiter lebten in häusern wie diesem
die bauten sie aus dem salzgestein dass
es hier gibt
an den abgelegenen und unwirtlichen ort
muss alles zum leben an transportiert
werden auch trinkwasser
trotzdem floriert die bergbaugemeinde
hier sehen sie einen generator der für
wasser verwendet wurde und die leitungen
für den strom
die glühende hitze und die anderen
gefahren schreiten die glückssucher
nicht ab bald folgen größere unternehmen
1945 wird eine 75 kilometer lange
eisenbahnlinie gebaut sie bringt das
kostbare kalisalz zum hafen von
marseille fatma im heutigen eritrea
die eisenbahn steigerte die produktion
und lockte noch mehr menschen an auf dem
höhepunkt wurden hier 50.000 tonnen
jährlich abgebaut es war ein ort der
möglichkeit ein ort an dem man reich
werden konnte
das kalisalz ist ein exportschlager
doch die arbeitsbedingungen sind extrem
das wasser ist sauer werden künftig
salzige flüssigkeit verletzt
die bergleute arbeiteten am heißesten
ort der erde die arbeit war sehr
gefährlich dennoch überstiegen aus ihrer
sicht die chancen risiken bei weitem
das geschäft lief gut war aber nicht von
dauer
die unerbittliche hitze und die gefahr
eines vulkanausbruchs haben die mine
immer bedroht am ende ist der
wirtschaftliche wandel nach dem ersten
weltkrieg der grund für ihren niedergang
es war einfacher kalisalz von
produzenten aus deutschland und den usa
zu beziehen
wenn sich der globale markt verändert
werden aus gewinnen schnell verluste und
wenn es kein profil mehr gibt die leute
ganz schnell
[Musik]
seitdem haben viele versucht die
ressourcen und äthiopiens brennender
sonne auszubeuten
doch mutter natur hat etwas dagegen es
ist kein zufall dass das wort alle sehr
viel bedeutet
[Musik]
land rover oder ein laster der ein paar
jahrzehnte dort steht löst sich
buchstäblich auf
es ist ein schrecklicher auch zum leben
mutter natur hat diese umgebung nicht
für menschen geschaffen es dauerte ein
paar jahrzehnte
aber dann haben sie es kapiert
[Musik]
das dorf liegt trostlos und verlassen da
trotzdem gibt es noch bergbauern dagegen
die mitglieder des stammes kommen oft
nachts mit kamel karawane graben große
salz platten aus laden sie auf die
kamele und bringen sie zum markt
geld zu verdienen gibt und reichtum
angehäuft werden kann
in der lauen weitergefahren alte und
neue
[Musik]
100 kilometer von venedig entfernt in
den bergen norditalien erwartet uns ein
weiteres rätsel
oberhalb von tonga rhone steht eine
riesige staumauer aber einen stausee
gibt es nicht was ist hier passiert
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg baute italien
viele wasserkraftwerke um strom für den
wiederaufbau zu erzeugen
in den bergen hat wasserkraft große
vorteile
dann mussten oben in einem engen tal das
wasser stauen und es dann schnell runter
fließen lassen so kann man günstig strom
die ingenieure bauen die valiant
staumauer sie ist das kernstück eines
ehrgeizigen wasserkraftprojekt es soll
die städte nord- italiens mit energie
versorgen
1960 wird der fünf kilometer langen
stausee mit wasser gefüllt
schon während der bauarbeiten warnten
sowohl einheimische als auch erfahrene
geologen der berg dahinter sei instabil
das wasser hatte enormes gewicht er übte
großen druck auf die umliegenden hänge
aus
am 9 oktober 1963 bewahrheiten sich die
befürchtungen der kritiker
250 millionen kubikmeter gestein brechen
aus dem hang und stürzen ins wasser
das problem war nicht nur die masse des
gesteins es war auch die ungeheure
geschwindigkeit
in 45 sekunden rauschte praktisch der
halbe hang ins wasser
der erdrutsch schickt einen tsunami über
den damm und hinunter in richtung london
die welle verdrängte die gesamte luft in
dem engen tal die druckwelle erreichte
das dorf schon vor dem wasser und
zerstörte die ersten häuser im nächsten
moment
voll und ganz
wie flüssiges schmirgelpapier dass das
dorf
gar ohne wird komplett zerstört fast
2000 menschen kommen ums leben
die ironie der geschichte ist dass das
dorf komplett ausradiert wurde der damm
selbst aber völlig intakt blieb
das staubecken jedoch ist nach dem
erdrutsch voller geröll es wird
aufgegeben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
heute gemahnt die vallon staumauer daran
die naturgewalten nicht zu unterschätzen
[Musik]
aus technischer sicht war das eine der
beeindruckendsten stau der mit der
geschichte so wurde er zu einem der
berüchtigsten
[Musik]
auf der idyllischen karibikinsel
montserrat liegt ein verschlafenes nest
praktisch auf einem pulverfass
sanfte hügel und kleine buchten schöne
einsame strände und dichte wälder ein
ort von ruhiger schroffe schönheit
willen schmiegen sich an den hang die
aussicht von dort ist spektakulär es
wirkt wie ein ehemaliges exklusives
resort
und grün
überall wäldern bergketten die bis
zählen wolken reichen
sagt inselgemeinden
aber warum sind die häuser zerstört und
zwar nicht nur in einem kleinen gebiet
sondern auf einem großen teil der insel
da sind viele verschiedene gebäude
teilweise liegen noch
regierungsdokumente herum
denn es ist rund mit vielen zimmern und
betten ein anderes ist voller
büromaterial und ein weiteres ist teil
eines einkaufszentrums
überall
in all dem verfall ist der frühere luxus
noch spürbar wer immer hier wohnte lebte
in saus und braus
sieht alles so aus als wären die leute
überstürzt aufgebrochen
das geschirr steht ihnen auf den tischen
videokassetten papiere liegen herum
so diese unglaubliche eile
sind überall gleichermaßen zerstört
das betraf nicht nur die häuser auf dem
hügel sondern in der ganzen stadt
erst auf den zweiten blick wird klar was
hier geschehen ist
man sich näher umschaut fällt auf dass
überall dieses grauen zeug die gebäude
einfach alles ist voll mit grauem star
[Musik]
16 kilometer lang und knapp zehn
kilometer breit dies ist die insel
montserrat
der einheimische führer normen kassel
ist einer der wenigen verbliebenen
bewohner er erinnert sich an die
hauptstadt plymouth von früher
[Musik]
schlimmer zwar immer besonders
einerseits eine sehr lebendige stadt
andererseits war die atmosphäre dort
sehr entspannt
heute liegt cliff in einer sperrzone
es ist gar nicht so einfach da rein zu
kommen
man spürt sofort wie schlimm dieses
unglück war und dass die gefahr immer
noch besteht
das war eine hauptstraße direkt ins
zentrum von plymouth
die zerstörten häuser der hauptstadt
erinnern an ihre vergangenheit
[Musik]
geschäftsleute übernachteten meistens im
flora fountain hotel wegen seiner lage
direkt in der stadt war sehr beliebt
ein viertel ihrer wirtschaftsleistung
verdankt die kleine insel damals dem
tourismus
hier war es sehr schön
welche leute und prominente aus der
ganzen welt kamen her
von für konferenzen partys hochzeiten
netz sind sie alle weg
die graue asche diplomat überzieht ist
der schlüssel zur lösung des rätsels
das ist der schicht vulkans free erhielt
er überragt die ehemalige hauptstadt und
das südliche montserrat mehr als 300
jahre war eher inaktiv
inselbewohner hatten ihn fast vergessen
es kam ihnen nicht in den sinn dass er
sich rühren könnte geschweige denn dampf
und asche spucken
die leute glaubten kaum was sie im radio
hörte das war seit dreihundert passiert
niemand nahm es richtig ernst wird ganze
insel wurde kalt erwischt
als er ein geräusch wie von
düsentriebwerken
niveau
aber ich fragte mich ob die us regierung
dahinter steckt
werden es gab zeiten in denen tief
fliegenden kampfjets f 18 11 16 uhr in
der gegend herum schwirrt
zu sein dachte ich aber das geräusch
hörte nicht auf und wir fragten uns was
das sein kann
dann erst merken wir dass es von den
bergen kam
im juni 1995 bricht das frier hills
vulkan aus
und zwar nicht klar dass die risse im
gestein und der ausströmende dampf diese
geräusche machten
dann kam die schwarze asche
wussten hier dass es der beginn
vulkanischer aktivität war
im vergleich zu anderen vulkanausbrüchen
ist die reduktion von 1995 noch relativ
harmlos noch hat das glühende magma die
oberfläche nicht erreicht
solche eruptionen treten auf wenn magna
auf grundwasser trifft der dampf schießt
nach oben und sprengt den fels das macht
krach wie donnerschläge
die herausgeschleuderte asche tochter in
tiefe dunkelheit
meine güte manchmal war es als ob der
tag zur nacht wurde man sah die hand vor
augen nicht so dunkel war
während die asche des ersten ausbruchs
dielen soll überzieht fliegen
wissenschaftler aus der ganzen welt ein
sie wollen wissen was der vulkan als
nächstes tun wird der seismologe
roddicks stewart ist dabei
als ich ankam hatte ich viele fragen er
wollte wissen was da los war
das ist die art vulkan die sich sehr
schnell von in angriff zu gefährden
verändert
einen monat nach dem ersten ausbruch
nahm die aktivität wieder zu die
wissenschaftler waren der ansicht die
sicherheit der menschen nicht mehr
garantieren zu können damit liegt
praktisch auf einem pulverfass
die bewohner werden in den norden von
montserrat gebracht dort sind sie sicher
diese ruinen sind die überreste ihrer
häuser
die häuser waren ihr ganzer stolz
all die verlassenen gebäude an den
hängen und darüber hinaus gebaut aus
schweiß und tränen ein vermögen wert
viele lassen sich nicht überreden ihre
häuser zu verlassen
jeden tag mussten die bewohner eine
schwierige entscheidung treffen bleiben
und zusehen wie ihre existenz
zusammenbricht oder abbauen und ihr
leben
die inselbewohner schafften es irgendwie
ein fast normales leben mit der
ständigen bedrohung zu führen
sie kannten die risiken und akzeptierten
sie
ist mit asche bedeckt aber noch hat der
vulkan keine lava gespuckt die
wissenschaftler befürchten allerdings
dass das schlimmste noch bevorsteht
die lava aus diesem vulkan ist so
zähflüssig dass sie keinen strom bilden
kann sie kommt heraus bleibt oben am
gipfel und formt das was wir einen
lavadom nennen
der drum blockiert die mündung des
vulkans wie ein tropfen der unter einem
enormen druck steht
die frage ist wie lange er im stand
halten kann
[Musik]
viele der bewohner sind längst geflohen
einige jedoch spielen ein tödliches
glücksspiel
[Musik]
leute ignorierten die anordnungen und
kehrten in die sperrzone zurück
die erstarrte lava verstopft die öffnung
und im inneren des vulkans steigt der
druck des magmas weiter und weiter
bis er sich im juni 1997 schließlich in
einer gewaltigen eruption entlädt der
druck wurde einfach zu groß es kam zu
einem heftigen ausbruch
am 25 juni 1997 starben hier viele
menschen eine der schlimmsten tage
meines lebens
als leiter des flughafens wird norman
chris l zeuge der schrecklichen
ereignisse
die lavaströme nahmen kein ende so
umschrieb heftiger und heftiger dann
ließen die wissenschaftler die sirene
zur evakuierung des flughafens erhöhen
eine lawine aus pulverisierter lava
asche und gas
sehr sehr schnell und sehr zerstörerisch
extrem gefährlich
obwohl der pyroklastischen strom
runterkam und die häuser zerstörte
konnte man eine deutliche
demarkationslinie erkennen
das krankenhaus und die anderen gebäude
oben am hang blieben unberührt
es war erstaunliche bestimmte teile von
klemme verwüstet wurden und andere
einfach stehen blieben
millionen tonnen asche regnen auf die
insel
und flussbetten werden teils meterhoch
damit gefüllt viele die in ihren häusern
geblieben sind bezahlen mit dem leben
da sie gut leben
am abend kam eine frau den hügel runter
wir trafen sie ungefähr hier
sie sagte sie habe es als einzige
geschafft
einige meiner kollegen sind damals
draufgegangen
ich habe sie nie wiedergesehen
in den nächsten vier monaten explodierte
vulkan 75 mal
blume versinkt unter heißer asche
ein bürokratischer strom traf das
parlamentsgebäude und löste ein feuer
aus
fast alle häuser hier brannte da unten
sehen sie noch einige verkohlte
überreste
als die leute sahen wie players brannte
wurde ihnen klar dass es nie wieder so
werden würde das war
irgendwann versiegen die lavaströme aber
das ist noch nicht das ende der tragödie
das feucht tropische klima löst bald den
nächsten schicksalsschlag aus viele der
häuser sind nicht mit lava oder asche
bedeckt sondern mit schlamm so hart wie
beton wie konnte es
gab viel regen und das wasser nahm auf
dem weg nach unten all dieses material
mit diese schlammlawinen entwickelten
ungeheure kraft rissen felsen und bäume
mit schlimmer wurde fast vollständig
verschüttet
im laufe der jahre erwischte es zunächst
die unteren abschnitt dann ging es immer
weiter auf einige gebäude sind
vollständig begraben
wurde endgültig evakuiert und als
geisterstadt zurückgelassen
[Musik]
im augenblick schläft der sophia hills
vulkan
die folgen des ausbruchs sind noch immer
spürbar
früher lebten mehrere tausend familien
in place und umgebung
alle mussten auswandern
das brachte insel das genick
die bevölkerung ging von über 10.000 auf
2.500 zurück
jetzt sind das ungefähr 4900
der norden von monster zeigt erste
anzeichen der erholung
er liegt außerhalb der reichweite des
vulkans
die bevölkerung wird sie liegt jetzt bei
5.000 der tourismus läuft wieder an die
leute hier sind sehr treu bleiben selbst
mit einem hamster als nachbarn
[Musik]
in usbekistan gibt es eine karge
wüstenlandschaft
aber sie ist nicht ganz das was sie zu
sein scheint 80 kilometer von der küste
wirken diese schiffswracks ziemlich
deplaziert merkwürdig schiffe in der
wüste wo ein schiff ist da ist
normalerweise auch wasser aber hier ist
weit und breit kein
das stadtwappen deutet allerdings darauf
hin dass die schiffe durchaus hierher
gehören
was steckt hinter dieser bizarre
szenerie
in den 1960 er jahren liegt die stadt
new york auf einer halbinsel im aralsee
den viertgrößten binnengewässer der welt
almaz towa schiff arbeitet damals in der
boomenden fischereiindustrie
mehr als 200 schiffe waren hier tätig
und über 100 schiffe transportierten den
fisch zur konservenfabrik
dort arbeiteten 1200 leiter und
produzierten bis zu zwölf millionen
dosen fisch pro jahr
seit 1990 werden hier keine fische mehr
gefangen der see ist zur wüste geworden
es gibt immer weniger wasser
es reichte nicht mehr für die gärten
oder für die landwirtschaft
kaum zu glauben diese katastrophe haben
menschen herbeigeführt
der aralsee wird von zwei flüssen
gespeist als die usbekische regierung
beschließt die baumwollproduktion zur
priorität zu machen werden die flüsse
kurzerhand umgeleitet mit verheerenden
folgen
das war ökologischer selbst wird
das wasser reichte nicht mehr für den
see
ist es sehr heiß und die meiste zeit
sonnig
mit ohne wasserzufluss begann der see zu
verdiensten
in nur dreißig jahren sinkt der
wasserspiegel um fast 17 meter die
küstenlinie geht stellenweise um 150
kilometer zurück
heute ist der größte teil des sees
ausgetrocknet eine schicht aus staub
salz und rückständen von pestiziden
bedeckt den boden
und der wind weht die giftige mixtur
über das land
[Musik]
vor der küste chinas liegt die insel
taiwan
dort entdecken wir ein halb
eingestürztes gebäude mit vielen
skulpturen und aufwendigen verzierungen
[Musik]
es hat höchst dekorative türen statue
und dann diese drachen
lücking hilfe schaut man zu diesem
tempel hoch sieht er echt toll aus
schaut man nach unten stellt man fest
dass er eingestürzt ist
er ist völlig zerstört überall sind
trümmer
das ist der wunsch ein tempel in der
stadt
sein dach ist noch fast intakt
doch darunter ist er eine ruine
so sieht man ihn störten beton und
schiefe pfeiler ob er von wien gesprengt
worden wäre
aus irgendeinem grund ist die ruine
stehengeblieben
tempel ist zu einer gedenkstätte
geworden pilger besuchen ihn
welche kräfte waren hier am werk hatten
sie einen natürlichen ursprung oder
stecken düsteren machenschaften dahinter
der wunsch ein tempel ist nicht so alt
wie er auf den ersten blick aussieht er
wurde 1923 erbaute und er ist nicht das
einzige bauwerk auf der insel das schwer
beschädigt ist
25 kilometer entfernt in der stadt
taishan liegt ein wesentlich höheres
gebäude in trümmern
ein dreistöckiges gebäude komplett
eingestürzt mit räumen unterschiedlicher
größe es sieht nach einem recht
funktionalen gebäude aus schaut man
hinein sieht man stühle und tafeln
in das eingangstor eingestürzt eine
laufbahn aufgeworfen und voller risse
und plötzlich wird klar das war eine
schule man hofft nur dass keine kinder
drin waren als das passierte
das ist dieckmann von junior highschool
viele in taiwan erinnern sich noch an
den tag an dem die schule und der tempel
verwüstet worden
[Musik]
für lucio ist der 21 september 1999 ein
tag der sein leben für immer verändert
hat
ich kann gegen elf nach hause zum still
und ging
bekam ich plötzlich starker
kopfschmerzen
es fühlte sich an als hätte ich steine
gegessen
ich war lebendig begraben ich fragte
mich waren das die kommunisten gewesen
das verhältnis zwischen china und taiwan
war immer schon angespannt deshalb
glaubten manche zunächst an einen
chinesischen angriff
welche kraft hat die gebäude zerstört
war es ein militärschlag der
volksrepublik china
als soweit schon sich aus den trümmern
befreit ergibt sich ein anderes bild
ich kletterte nach draußen und sah dass
alle weinten
es gab auch nachbeben deshalb wackelten
immer noch die häuser
nicht ein militärschlag hat taiwan
getroffen sondern ein schweres erdbeben
straßen rissen auf brücken stürzten ein
und erdrutsche leiteten flüsse um
wodurch sich neue seen bildeten das
erdbeben löst einen prozess aus der als
boden verflüssigung bekannt ist der
untergrund wird extrem weich und das
führt zu schlammlawinen und erdrutschen
in einem an die hügel sahen aus wie ein
theater teppich es war als hätte die
erde die häuser förmlich verschlungen
fast zweieinhalb tausend menschen werden
getötet
300.000 sind obdachlos
es ist das zweitschlimmste beben in der
geschichte taiwans
auch forsch beim bau der häuser kommt
durch das beben zutage
90er jahren erlebte taiwans bauindustrie
einen enormen boom hier sieht man was
passiert wenn man aufbau und
sicherheitsvorschriften wenig rücksicht
nimmt
die natur erteilt den menschen eine
lektion
das beben vom 21 september war für ganz
taiwan eine sehr schmerzliche erfahrung
wir versuchen es zu verdrängen aber es
sollte uns eine lehre sein hoffentlich
sorgt die regierung für mehr aufklärung
über solche naturkatastrophen und wir
brauchen vorbeugende maßnahmen
es ist kaum zu glauben in taiwan gibt es
über 4.000 erdbeben pro jahr nur 20 bis
30 davon sind so stark dass die menschen
sie bemerkten
das zeigt wie wichtig es ist sich
vorzubereiten damit künftige
generationen so was nicht erleben müssen
das erdbeben vom 21 september gibt dazu
einen wichtigen anstoß
schon 1996 war im ganzen land ein
netzwerk aus sensoren installiert worden
während des bebens sammeln sie riesige
datenmengen
es war das erste erdbeben in der
geschichte das so detailliert
aufgezeichnet wurde
es lieferte wichtige daten für
zukünftige präventionsmaßnahmen dadurch
veränderte sich sehr
man arbeitet als führerin in der
ehemaligen schule die heute eine
gedenkstätte ist
[Musik]
dieses klassenzimmer war direkt über der
bruch juli
waren die auswirkungen auf die gebäude
gewaltig
aber die schule bietet noch etwas
anderes etwas völlig einzigartiges
sie führt direkt am spielplatz der
schule vorbei
er war früher eine laufbahn sie wurde
nach oben gedrückt
als genau an dieser stelle zwei
tektonische platten auseinanderdriften
wird die schule regelrecht entzwei
gerissen
zum ersten mal kann eine
verwerfungslinie so detailliert
betrachtet und analysiert werden die
laufbahn sorgt dafür dass die offene
bruchlinie vor weitere erosion geschützt
bleibt
das war eine große chance für die
seismologie und auch will die
entwicklung erdbebensicher bautechnische
aus der katastrophe erwuchs eine große
herausforderung
wie können wir die menschen in zukunft
schützen
es ist der beginn einer neuen ära die
naturgewalten haben verheerenden tribut
gefordert
aber taiwan hat daraus gelernt
[Musik]
ab sofort wird vollkommen anders gebaut
das beste beispiel der wolkenkratzer
taipei taiwan
wurde 2004 eröffnet und das gebäude war
damals eine ansage an die ganze welt und
dazu gehörte auch was immer an
naturkatastrophen kommt wir sind
vorbereitet
wann wurde in einem pagoden ähnlichen
stil gebaut und war bis 2007 der höchste
wolkenkratzer der welt
und es ist immer noch ein wunderwerk
moderner bautechnik es hat isolatoren
stoßdämpfer und einen stimmungsdämpfer
zwischen dem 88 und 92 stock
wenn das gebäude schwankt absorbieren
die dämpfer die stöße und reduzieren die
vibrationen
die ruine des tempels in g g steht da
wie eingefroren
auch er ist von holz pagoden inspiriert
die für diese region typisch sind
wie bei vielen älteren gebäuden in
taiwan haben die architekten die
zerstörerische energie der tektonik
nicht berücksichtigt beim erdbeben vom
21 september 1999 bricht der tempel in
sich zusammen
für viele ist das beben bis heute
traumatisch
[Musik]
seit 20 jahren schlafe ich schlecht in
meinem herzen nehmen die nachbeben kein
ende
wie an der taiwanesen ist schon
vorbereitet auf das nächste beben
sobald die sensoren ein erdbeben
registrieren werden die leute per sms
informiert sie erfahren wo das
epizentrum ist und wie stark das beben
ist so können sie sich gut vorbereiten
es ist ein sehr gutes wahnsystem taiwan
ist doch das nächste beben vorbereitet
[Musik]
heute sind viele der bauten vergessen
und verlassen manche bei ihnen erinnern
an bessere zeiten andere waren einst
leuchtende beispiele für technologischen
fortschritt sie sind zeugen unsere
vergangenheit die bis in die gegenwart
überdauert haben
[Musik]